yeah welcome to this video playing total
fish cake from the US let's see fifteen
minute game okay let's stay within this
fianchetto territory okay this is one of
them the better setups for black very
solid
it's similar to him to Queens pawn
opening like the the tora tora attacker
the the trump offski yeah why it's
plenty ER after the exchange on d5 s
played e3 and e4 trying to utilize this
extra pawn in the center why does not
playing default this is some very rarely
a good idea to set up the Queens gambit
exchange structure with the pub with the
bishop on g2 this doesn't make so much
sense the idea is to go e form let's see
how he sets up his pieces it's um quite
flexible but black can do we can play
especially the bishop he could play that
to e7 2d6 to c5 everything how every
post them has some some point to it yeah
26 ok so let's continue Knight c3 and
then e for the next move pretty much no
matter what he plays
yeah maybe it maybe first Queens it too
with an idea so that I'm not yeah this
is probably better Quincy tuam has got
the the site threat night b5 and after
ye form I'm not in a pin with 95 the one
I would have preferred if or immediately
he maybe could have taken play 95 with
the somewhat awkward pin this is not not
happening here
no this is some
after c64 on a typical position okay
didn't play that yeah it's not not so
clear what this accomplishes even after
a three wouldn't he just take know
probably okay let's get the bishop am
b.tech see also was interesting I just
didn't want to spend ages on on this
decision and be quick for once uh-huh
yeah this probably was the ATM yeah okay
let's play play this enum any restraint
fashion I can just play like III be
three here 33 we should be to setting up
a voice very quick here okay so I got
good posts for my bishops and I got a
very flexible porn structure so i can
change the pawn structure later in fact
it right now I'm thinking about a form
yeah let's do that and before as
Princess next move I guess Quincy to and
then I'm going for a form and I'm going
for a form this should transpose into a
very am very nice structure
if you place d for now this is an
excellent position 92 okay one Bishop
see one and then f 4 i've got four
against three on the King side and he's
got a dead majority on the queenside
Saudi for as some defaults very close to
positional capitulation Saudi forces
terrible cannot do that he probably he
needs to think about moves like c4 down
c4 maybe see form
hmm
okay or the other one okay if you place
d for this is so bad I mean I don't mind
to lose more time but look at ones later
I want to I want to get a fire into the
mix protecting me for threatening you
five
92 maybe I should have gone 92 which
would have taken care of the c5 c4 idea
hmm
yeah I should have done that I think you
really can get some decent play now we
see phone or taking on c4
def does he want to place afore I don't
know
oh yeah
hmm
yeah I don't know it doesn't look nice
for me somehow yeah maybe I can take
take and play a form f45 yeah I don't
like it I should have played 92 this was
much stronger it would have really taken
care of all this this counter play
want to play you five maybe you can
reckon in plano chief form
yeah fill out her too much counter play
him far too much and I like that for me
this is changing yeah yeah but this is
probably helping me because some
attempts my coordination actually I was
I was fearing much more that she would
go see three at some point or take on
b3s that you have a protected person now
he basically needs to exchange only
three and after a 45 I should have the
better game again check
hmm yeah I could even take twice but
again it's not the best move justjust
this is fine threatening Brooke and now
if five intending Bishop takes d5 and h3
trapping the night and this double
threat is too much I hope
hmm
yeah didn't see that one
hmm
yeah and Luke c3 this is the real
problem Bishop h3h wife takes takes he's
got looks III at the end hmm
hmm it's hard to believe that there
shouldn't be something for white really
can't believe that this at all Knight g4
d for this kind of all hangs by a thread
tactics really hard to believe
I still don't see a move
Brooks III or whatever I do he will play
Roxy three
Bishop 5 this night III
so also no tactic yeah okay maybe maybe
there is some tactic if I let's say Roxy
3b3 the special d5 and d6 maybe maybe I
can do something along these lines
always 93 can you believe that
ok trying for for a simple solution
ok yeah why h5 what what else
alright so let's let's check this first
okay it's got a couple of games played
if I'm always getting a bit skeptical if
if they don't play obvious only move
instantly okay but this is probably
Iraqis got lots of games played ok so I
wanted to go for this year and then hope
that this rook is active enough to get
something ok at least he played a
passive move here rook c8 was so what I
feared more ok
but anyway how do i do I make some
progress here
yeah can i activate the king
oopsie aight i mean at one point you
will see it King f2 Luke c8 is just good
for black
maybe I should I should just just double
on the 707 come on let's let's gamble on
this it is probably enough to to be
maintaining quality whoopsie seven lucky
seven andy sixx is kind of ideas that
should be at least a draw maybe there's
this more no no
it's also it can always play rook c8 and
abandoned upon himself go rooks he do
next and I'm in trouble with my open
King so this was possible already
instead of Ruby aids was quite a gamble
hmm maybe Roxy some rope design it is
quick and each 60 to c6 idea there's two
parts fa de Paul against the f porn and
there are some always some technical
possibilities like f5 e66 immediately
some not so easy maybe maybe he needs to
I can think about Luke 87 but I have f5
f5 phone now maybe a five intending
check on the eight and then look a jade
made this kind of meeting ideas
hmm curious
uh-huh
not sure what this is doing I will I
play route d7 anyway g6 is not really
helping up he wants to return upon oopsy
foyer ok this is this is an idea
probably yeah I can't need to take it I
cannot know I need to take it I need to
take here and now the play route before
of course yeah well look III is so
passive if you don't want to want to
play that yeah I can I cannot give give
the ball up I mean okay
hmm
yeah I hope I'm not overdoing things
here in trying to continue this intense
look at five andrew f form so look be4
at five and threatening e6 thus King
evade allowed that so that maybe needs
to attend to this threat and then I have
a look at form yeah look at for coming
aha so maybe maybe there is something
maybe there's something to play for
okay so so G for ya g4 mataji for our
and I can play with chief five look
before as always the problem look G for
a little before butch if i'll check this
f5 okay
I take f7 route before
yeah I need to check him not much else
to do I will I can I look before i can
actually play rook h4 this is good look
edge from
a google for now maybe I still still
need to go to h phone
our way toward with i can i can use the
check and play book check look over
prolly we should should take this
opportunity he can activate the king of
course but I probably needed to do it
anyway
there's something better probably not
King f3 I can take a five with check
this is shanks very important so I'm
here I need to head this way anyway
check
it's probably and it's probably still a
draw
no check this is not a drum check black
forfeits due to this connection yep
which amounts to resigning yeah I can
group kingi 3i just exchange and then
the FDA porn I like this then okay if I
go here he can play this and threatens
but I can oops i can play here and then
it just promotes it was a draw really he
could hear here i can relate that and he
can just play okay too and there's
nothing going on I i know i'm not sure
if i could have done something better
okay i can i can try to i can try
different things here
but I don't really think it did helps
it's still now this rook here is still
very active and it's hard to make any
progress even after winning the spawned
it was the only try this f5 was the only
try for something check now check check
yeah this is the only thing he cannot
and he can opt-in like he cannot do
everything else draws yeah this was
really curious but I think one very
important point was here this rook d5
was this is already quite quite tricky
for what and hear some active play rugby
troop c 8 after that I'm probably I'm in
the game again and this is very active
of course still probably a draw because
she's got the look on the seventh-ranked
that's all I think my main position with
error was that I've didn't play this 92
this was was really bad here here okay I
can also take on d5 it's not bad but
after I need to do the same this is
probably the way to go covering c4 and
then attending look you born maybe f4
and so on he can't play that okay this
is interesting black and can try that
okay but this means that i should
probably take here and play this
position which isn't too bad i mean look
at this I've got to two bishops I'd say
here and then 92 to see for this is good
for a slight edge I was a bit more
ambitious though but it didn't really
did it didn't really help me him he was
an excellent excellent shape may be here
you know I should probably take it 5 and
this here gets gets really tricky now we
can take on b3 now and probably win yeah
it was it was a crab Chang yeah and then
busted I really completely lost control
over this position very quickly should
probably take on c4 first DC form check
and she defaults good wow I didn't see
anything in this game I thought okay but
it's got look c5 also like this and
terrible terrible position check check
and this is fine for black really
amazing I think this is amazing it looks
like to me like black is hanging by a
thread but it's probably all right I
comp at least didn't see anything and it
already gives us is good for black hmm
quite curious yeah an interesting game I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching